by popular demand its Muppet Treasure
Island why are the popular demands this
year films that didn't do financially
well well whatever this is the second
Muppet film to be an actual adaptation
of the literary classic the first one
being the previous film Christmas Carol
and what Christmas Carol being such a
big hit you would think audiences would
go and see this one as well but from
what I hear it didn't do so hot and I'd
be lying if I said I didn't see why but
at the same time look it's Tim Curry Tim
Curry with the Muppets he practically is
a muppet this is a match made in heaven
okay well let's look at the story as if
you don't know it's pretty much the
story of Treasure Island a young boy
named Jim Hawkins comes across a
treasure map this leads to a giant
expedition only this time the captain is
played by Kermit the Frog and the
majority of the cast seem to be Muppets
as well that is of course for the cook
Long John Silver played by Tim Curry by
God is this a match made in heaven and
yes it's just as entertaining as you
think it would be I don't think I'm
giving anything away by saying this but
Long John Silver has an evil plan and
he's gonna mutiny the ship to find the
treasure and yeah come on you've all
read the book you know what happens and
it sticks pretty close to it for the
most part it still has a lot of Muppet
isms that most of the time are welcomed
the only strange thing is that one of
the most popular Muppet characters Miss
Piggy doesn't come in until the last
third in fact the more thing about she
didn't get much of a Rowling Christmas
carol either did she I guess neither of
these stories had that big a focus on
women so you can kind of understand why
but come on you're already taking so
many liberties in other areas why
couldn't you get Miss Piggy in there at
least a lot earlier well much like
Christmas Carol it does try to really
stick to the source material and kind of
a feel just like I said this time with
Muppets in the part they'll have little
fourth wall jokes who have songs that
suddenly come out of nowhere and kind of
like Muppet Christmas Carol it's fine I
guess people had a little bit more of a
connection with Christmas Carol because
hey it's Christmas it's already gonna be
a sentimental connection and be there
did seem to be a little bit more heart
to it maybe just because of the story it
is with this one it just kind of feels
like a longer month
show sketch at least with the Muppets
when it needs to be serious with Jim
Hawkins and stuff it does it fine I mean
it's not the best telling or anything
but it's totally passable
the songs are just as good as Christmas
Carol - I actually love the intro song
so much I put on my top 11 favorite
villain songs list in Hans Zimmer who I
swear can do no wrong does the
orchestrations for these songs and they
sound pretty badass except one are not
supposed to sound man as I'm it you know
outwards and speaking of singing
silliness let's talk about Tim Curry
this is a guy who even if he does a bad
performance
it'll still be a good performance
there's just some kind of magic to him
that makes it so much fun to watch I
can't even really decide if this is a
good performance or not it's just
insanely entertaining just seeing him
look down to cover the Frog give us a
little girl I got a captain I mean how
can you not fall in love with this guy
though to his credit he does manage to
get a nice connection with Jim Hawkins
as well as he's supposed to in the story
and yeah whether you want to see it as
it's so awkward it's charming or it's so
charming it's awkward he does really
work in the role I almost wouldn't mind
seeing him in another renditions to
Treasure Island where he is Long John
Silver like a serious one but that's not
what this is this is a bunch of hand
puppets trying to retell this story in a
goofy way with some serious moments and
I think it just kind of depends on what
mood you're in there's nothing really
spectacular about I mean even multi
Christmas have more of a visual sense
than this one did but if you say the
title outloud Muppet Treasure Island
with Tim Curry and you say to yourself
that might be a little fun that's
exactly what you'll get I get the
feeling there's better renditions of
this tale but as one that has little
Muppets going around singing songs and
such it's totally fine shiver your
Timbers and find out for yourself
you